can you hear me can you hear me
awesome I've been planning this for
years
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your glue I bear that you'll be fine
without it
[Music]
hey y'all some exciting news before we
dive into this episode the minimalists
are going to host a private podcast and
live stream exclusively for our patreon
supporters we're calling this ask the
minimalists anything the first session
will take place next month that's August
2017 anyone who contributes 2 dollars or
more over at our patreon page can attend
this special live stream and you can't
make the live stream itself the live
session the live podcast don't worry
you'll still have access to the private
video and the private audio podcast
efforts recorded we hope to do this at
least once a quarter maybe more
frequently for our patreon supporters
and please note that none of the money
from our patreon campaign goes to our
personal bank accounts rather what we're
going to do is use these funds to build
our own new podcast studio and a film
studio which is going to allow us to do
a bunch of really cool things like take
live colors on the air improve overall
audio quality and bring guests on the
show we're also going to hire a
full-time filmmaker to create a video
version of this podcast and we also want
to produce a bunch of other meaningful
video creations like webseries TV shows
interviews documentaries video essays
and more and because we refuse to
clutter our podcasts with advertisements
patreon really is the best way for us to
fund these creative endeavors together
so let me ask you this are you willing
to help if so please become a patron
today head on over to patreon comm slash
the minimalists or you can go to our
website it's just the minimalists comm
and click on the donate button at the
top we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well and please know that your
support is greatly appreciated together
we will create something meaningful
hey let's record a podcast Cincinnati my
name is Joshua fields Milburn and this
guy right here is Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalist and we
are live in Cincinnati and Bogaerts you
have seen so many concerts here and it's
awesome actually I was talking to Ryan
before this actually and I said you know
we've never played Bogaerts before and
he looked at me and said we don't play
anything so I guess we still won't be
playing Bogaerts tonight but we will be
answering your questions there's a
microphone up here and if you want to
come up ask some questions comments
concerns smart-alecky remarks you are
welcome to do that and it might be a
little bit bright you might want to dim
that a bit for the folks up front I
would appreciate that I'm sure they
would - howdy
what's your name hey Kyle you can get
way closer way way closer see how close
I am just like that you got it okay okay
hi guys hey Kyle so I just actually
wanted to get up and introduce myself
I've never met you guys so nice to meet
you and I am the community leader for
the Cincinnati chapter of the minimalist
meetup right so we have some members
here tonight and this is Heather she
runs the dayton group as well I know so
for those of you guys who don't know
that we exist we do and we have local
chapters we have an awesome one here we
meet on we have a Facebook group where
myself and our members post articles and
content that we find to be like add
value and interesting and then we also
have meetings once a month and we get
together and they're really open to
anybody for people to come so if tonight
you're looking to continue the
conversation or just to be a part of
community around minimalism here in
Cincinnati is something that we're
really looking to build and this is your
official invitation so
join us so if you make a request we will
accept you as a member into the group
and our next meeting is in July and we
would love to see you
that's awesome Kyle thanks uh tell them
like what is a what is like a typical
Meetup look like what do y'all do um we
normally have a theme and I'll send out
like maybe a link to a couple articles
around that theme whether it's like
minimal kitchens and minimalist
groceries something like that or you
know and then we'll have a conversation
around that but more than anything it's
kind of just getting to know each other
and a forum for asking questions
sometimes it can be hard in our daily
lives to find support for minimalism and
with our families and friends and so
this is kind of a space for you to just
explore it more and feel really
comfortable and get to meet people who
are asking the same questions well I
definitely appreciate you being there so
a few years ago Ryan and I went out on
the road we did a hundred city tour and
people kept coming up to us saying how
do we connect with people locally and we
never had a good answer for that because
there'd be four or five hundred people
in a room and that's great but like once
you leave here then you go back and you
might feel a bit disconnected and how do
I find other people who are open minded
they may not be like-minded they might
not have the same exact interests or
beliefs as you but what we found is the
people in these groups have similar
values so what we did is we left behind
free local meetup groups in a hundred
different cities so since that is one
Dayton's one folks from Kentucky here at
all yeah so we've got one in Louisville
as well and and so what we tried to do
is just leave something behind we're on
and I don't have any control room we
don't want we don't want anything from
you we just want to leave something
behind so you can connect and so you can
talk about whatever you want it's in a
weird way would you would you agree that
it's a support group I've heard that
from a lot of different folks in these
groups it's different kind of support
though like you said quite often we have
questions and it just it's about going
and getting different people's
perspectives on some of those questions
and so we feel like you need support in
any way
can do with stuff and minimalism and
decluttering but I can do with your your
career or it can have to do with your
with finances with relationships you can
talk to people about some of these
things who aren't going to judge you but
who'll listen and at least provide a bit
of a perspective so thank you so much
both of you for being here I'm so
grateful and if you're interested just
go to minimalist org that's where you
find all hundred cities by the way
minimalist org
yeah just click on Cincinnati Dayton or
whatever your city is thank you so much
for being here yeah
are you upstanding how are you okay so
Miami can you hear me okay my name is
Heather and I am a Dayton community
leader so Dayton represent thank you
guys that is so let me tell you why
that's awesome because Ryan I have done
five events in the last five years in
Dayton and we've said let's let it
breathe for a year because we always go
back to Dayton every single year it's a
hometown and we love it there but we'll
be back there next year or eventually
but thank you all for making the drive
down grateful for that I just want to
touch on the group also so if you live
further north in Cincinnati you're
always welcome to join our Dayton group
we were meeting up at a Starbucks and
we're meeting up at another place now a
little close but we do the same kind of
things we we just get together we talk
it's a big kind of support group you
just we talked about the challenges you
have a decluttering a big topic is
getting your family members on board so
we're just there to support each other
it's great to get together with
like-minded people especially like this
but on a smaller scale we can all talk
and have a voice and so I really urge
you if you live further north in
Cincinnati seek us out we have the
Facebook group I also created the
minimalist life on Facebook which is
like 160 thousand members Wow let's kill
it every one of us love these guys so
you can join that one and like come see
us in Dayton too
thank you appreciate it howdy hi what's
your name I'm Ali no I'm not I have a
question so you guys have been on tour
for a really long time this is your
second tour I think right this is our
eighth tour in seven years you've done
many tours so my question for you is you
get a lot of these questions and I want
to know if you've gotten one in that
time that has affected the way that you
think about minimalism or that has
affected your personal minimalism
journey that's come from the outside
yeah all of the questions have led me to
shape it's one of the reasons we go out
on the road right now is to listen I
mean it's one of the most important
things because it's easy for us we're
just backstage talking about this
actually it's easy for us to like sit in
our proverbial ivory tower in Montana
and sort of bloviate on our keyboards
about minimalism and that doesn't do any
good right like I want to hear what
people's struggles are what their
concerns are what their questions are I
tell you one thing that's come up a lot
lately has to do with privilege and and
that that's one that is an interesting
topic to me because I've seen both sides
of the socio-economic spectrum growing
up really poor we get our electric
turned off occasionally and you we had
food stamps and my mom had had some
alcohol issues and and so it was a very
discontented household growing up and
then when I went into my 20s I started
making decent money and then eventually
became what I would consider relatively
wealthy and realized that both sides of
it gave me different perspectives and I
had a weird kind of privilege now I
didn't recognize it at the time but I
had the privilege of poverty and and
that was a weird thing for me because I
don't think I would have known that had
I not experienced the other side of it
but but I also now have a different kind
of privilege as well I sort of have a
megaphone in a way like it literally
almost you know a microphone hear that
it's really about what we do with the
privileges that we have I think all of
us have a certain amount of privilege
and there are some some systemic
privileges that lead to oppression and
racism and those are especially
insidious and we need to be able to
address that
especially from a point of privilege but
there are other types of privilege as
well and I think it's up for up to me
and Ryan to to use some of the
privileges that we have now to
contribute to the world in in different
ways so give you an example a few months
ago we contributed to building a
orphanage on the us-mexico border we've
done a lot of things for charities and
in different places where we have the
opportunity to do that but it's not just
us doing it it's giving other people the
opportunity and shining a light on why a
contribution is important and so I would
say there are a lot of questions that
have come up that have shaped me that
one is coming up a little bit more and
more and it's one that I'm thinking a
lot more about and I don't have any
definitive answers and I think that's a
good thing like it's making me ask some
questions internally yeah I mean just
the kind of echo what he was saying in
the beginning in 2000 so we published a
minimalism live the meaningful life like
at the end of 2011 and we went on a tour
and we just kind of did 2-3 weeks here
and you know a few stops here a few
stops there but you know first I
remember like that very first city we
went to in Saint Petersburg it was a
very like apropos place to start for you
know it's where kind of it started for
Joshua with his mom stuff and we open up
the trunk and I just remember looking at
like three duffel bags a garment bag
just all this other stuff we were
traveling like a week and I look at Josh
so I'm like dude we are hypocrites man
like look at all this crap were carrying
with us and you know that that was like
the first lesson that we learned on
Torah was like even though we're only
going to be gone for a week or so we had
carried all of this just in case
with us and in fact you know Josh and I
we started talking about like how can we
get over this fear of all these just in
case items because you know I were going
to Florida so I brought a pair of
swimming trunks and we were going to be
down there for a week or so so maybe I
would go swimming twice in case one pair
got dirty I wanted to have a clean pair
that you know so I didn't have to wash
that dirty pair and well I've got a
third pair of swimming drug so I might
as well bring those to what if I go
swimming three times and after you know
kind of talking about all these just in
case items we realized that you know
anything not just that we brought on
tour with us or you know for if we're
going on vacation or something when
we're traveling we realize that any of
those things that we really feel like we
want to bring or even the things at home
that we want to hold on to look like you
know like I think about my drunk drawer
and like it it always somehow ends up
with like all these random cables I have
no idea like what none of it would
hardly any of them go to and we realized
like yeah if we just kind of let this
stuff go if something comes up like if I
go to Florida I brought only one person
women trucks and somehow I went to
swimmin and like I don't know I got
attacked by a shark and they ripped my
swimming trunks and I was healthy enough
to go swimming again like I could
probably go replace those swimming
trunks pretty easily in fact I could
probably do it for less than twenty
dollars in less than twenty minutes and
and that is something that Josh and I
have implemented from that very that
very first stop and I'll tell you at
first it sounds like well these guys are
crazy they're just going out and
spending $20.00 all the time but Josh
and I we have we have implemented that
over the last six years and we've used
it maybe five times between the both of
us now our our theory is that it works
99% of the time I mean there's always an
exception to the rule right but I mean
it has worked 100% of the time for Josh
and I and we lived in in the middle of
nowhere Montana it like this little town
called Phillipsburg population 871
stoplight in like thirty five hundred
square miles and even then
you know if we absolutely needed
something like there was a little corner
store there that there's still sosam we
were able to access things pretty easily
but yeah I mean that whole tour in fact
with that with that first book that we
wrote that's really what shaped
everything you see now I mean we went on
the road and it wasn't you know there
were there are no microphones there was
no stage there were no spotlights I mean
we literally just went out and met
people at coffee shops and we show up in
Knoxville Tennessee and no one showed up
like we were just sitting there and it
was like 10 or 15 minutes and Josh and I
are like well no big deal
we'll just we'll go ahead and go to the
next city and we'll have a cup of coffee
and yeah we'll go so we're getting up to
leave and as we were leaving like this
couple walks in and they're like you
guys are the minimalist we're like yeah
that's us and they're like oh yeah sorry
we're late we were we were coming to see
you guys so we ended up you know we
ended up hanging out with those two
folks and doing a lot of listening and
this guy told us a really awesome story
about how he had fasted and lost weight
and you know at the end of the day I
guess what I'm really getting at is is
that every single tour sup that we do we
are we're learning something and whether
it's the TEDx talks that you've seen or
if you haven't seen those and you know
this is the first time you're seeing a
speak tonight this is all an
amalgamation of all of that touring so
yeah I wouldn't trade it for the world
it's it's uh we've been touring a lot
but I freaking love it and what I'll say
- it makes it really easy on me when I
have an awesome partner I mean not only
do I have Josh my best friend but Moriah
my my partner who I live with in
Missoula Montana she is one of the most
supportive people I've ever had in my
life I mean the sometimes I have to
leave her for three or four weeks and we
will you know Skype or FaceTime on the
daily basis and this tour like it's
pretty awesome she's actually was able
to come with me I kind of had the
twister arm a little bit she's going to
coding school right now
and like she's doing an online and she
has to spend about six to eight hours a
day reading and doing this coding stuff
like sometimes I look at her computer
and it looks like she's hacking into the
matrix or something like it's
unbelievable and I was I was talking
about coming out to Ohio and she's like
oh you know I really think you know kind
of getting behind that I don't want to
fall too much further behind and I'm
like oh we'll find time come on so where
you at Moriah anyway she's out there
somewhere um but yeah long so long story
short having a partner like that really
helps really help Satori and go-go
amazingly well she sacrifices a lot and
there's it makes it a lot easier so
thanks more wherever you are out there
[Applause]
hi my name's Scott that was my sister
she introduced me to you guys by
fortunately dragging me here oh yeah
you're the ones right yeah hopefully did
hate it in um so I am actually in grad
school I'm doing that just because I
thought I wanted more money for a job
and I was kind of curious what you guys
would say to yourselves when you're
younger kind of a my age like to try to
convince yourself that maybe you need to
rethink about what makes you happy
versus the money like how you convince
yourself not to go after that high
paying job just because it's money man
um when I think about when I first like
got a taste of like the corporate world
and Josh showing me what you know what
he was making in the corporate world and
I just remember thinking to myself like
man like maybe maybe one day I can save
you know a million dollars and maybe I
can do that before you know I'm 65 maybe
I could retire earlier like you know 45
or 50 if I just really you know work
hard and and sell a bunch of cellphones
and and and and that's that was kind of
like in the back of my head this goal um
what I'll say man the problem with a
goal like that is what is that what what
is the money going to do for you because
like for me that million dollars I
really know what it was going to do
retirement like that's really kind of
what it was going to do so I think about
retirement and for me it's you know
having to having having free time having
more free time doing things that I like
to do travel and when I really thought
about what it took to do that it's not
even close to a million dollars so you
know the question I would be asking is
what are you going to do with that money
if you have just a blanket a blanket
number in your mind you've got to be
able to like say well a hundred thousand
is going to I'm going to buy my mom a
new house and another hundred thousand
going to buy my dad a new house in them
but if you don't if you don't have a
clear vision on why you want that then
you're going to be chasing it for the
rest of your life you ask me what I
would tell my younger self what I would
tell my younger self is like as soon as
I even started to get that itch to climb
the corporate ladder to make as much
money as possible I would tell myself
hey Ryan if you can't be happy now with
what you have it doesn't matter how much
money you get you're still not going to
be happy because at the end of the day
it was never the money it was a choices
that I was making with my my other
resources my time and my attention what
are you going to grad school for
mechanical engineering okay what are you
passionate about green architecture and
design okay
know that that's great and so going to
grad school for for that will aid your
passion in some way I'm hoping yeah
it'll help me get a job in that field
okay okay well that's not that's not a
bad thing so here's the way that I feel
about education I think I think it's
largely unnecessary these days and I
think it's an antiquated system you
[Applause]
what was the joke we were talking about
the the under one underwater dog walking
degree it kind of feels that way
sometimes where we get we get these
degrees where they don't really have a
practical use in the real world and I
think the better education is in formal
education where we could be on the job
sort of training and so my question for
you would be are there other ways to
pursue that passion without getting the
education because that said I'm never
going to go to a self-taught dentist
there there are some some education that
are necessary right and so I'm grateful
that my dentist has has his degree
although I couldn't tell you what school
he graduated from like that if it
wouldn't impress me more that he went to
Yale dental schools and whatever dental
school he actually went to what I care
about is sort of the bedside manner and
what kind of person he is and how
engaged he is that's far more important
to me than that certificate that's on
the wall it just happens to be in some
professions you you need that and so my
question for you is what are you trying
to why are you passionate about your
passion about you something to think
about really and then are there other
avenues to achieve that without going
this route of grad school because I'm
not saying there's anything inherently
wrong with with going this route but
because you're asking the question it
tells me that maybe there is for you
yeah alright I appreciate thanks for
being here oh thanks
hello got it
my name is Chaston I'm here with my wife
Mariah it's a pretty good name not a lot
of girls have that name so you're lucky
to find one that did not a lot of
cheston's out there either no there's
not my parents gave me that name so I'm
here to ask a question so my personality
if you were to look at it on personality
assessment Myers Brigg would be INTJ not
alone thank you yeah but your 9pj so you
wish you were alone this I'm a little
shaky up here but that's beside the
point
so whenever I look at something I think
okay do I really have an emotional tie
to this or is it something that I can
part with that's fairly easy for me
however not everyone at my house and
it's just Mariah and myself this is this
was spoken like a true introvert by the
way everybody at my house there's two of
us so not everyone is quite I - I we
have been following you guys have been -
minimalism for the past six months now
and Mariah is on board with it but there
are times - where sometimes I think I'm
a little too willing to part with an
object and I realize okay it's a little
more difficult for you so one what
advice would you give for someone who
does have a tendency to push away a
little too quickly so it's up to me I'd
get rid of everything except for the
possessions on my back but that's not
realistic and that's okay so what advice
would you give for that and - I have a
little bit of OCD and people tell me -
you're a little obsessed with this
minimalism thing you need to cool it
whether or not that's true as yet to be
decided so if it is do I really need to
cool my Jets or is it okay keep doing or
not doing so let's unpack that a little
bit for the folks who don't know what
the hell an INTJ is there's something a
personality assessment test called the
myers-briggs Type Indicator if you want
it if you want to take one yourself you
go to the minimalists comm slash MBTI
and there's like a quick online sort of
shortened attenuated version of that I
too am an INTJ and right and there's
three percent of you are by the way Ryan
is an ENFP and so we are essentially
polar opposites on the myers-briggs and
here's the nice thing about that we have
different beliefs we have different
personalities I'm an introvert he's an
extrovert one of us is on time the other
one's not yeah yeah we we have different
religious beliefs we voted for two
different people in the last election
so so there's more than two choices
people it's okay so so because we're
different we have different beliefs but
those beliefs are different paths to get
as to what our values are we do have
similar values
so we're I'm going to ask you to start
isn't your personality your personality
helps you understand how to better
interact with other people and that's
really nice for me I once I realized I
was an introvert somehow it took me like
28 years to really understand like oh I
need to be alone more than I am right
now then I was able to carve out that
time for myself that I need and that's
really important it set those
expectations and those boundaries even
with or especially with the people who
are closest to you because here's the
thing if it's people around you all the
time you're going to feel drained
obviously but if you carve out that
alone time it's so you can be your best
self with those other people when they
are around so if you need 60% of your
time to be alone time well you need a
vocation the supports that you need a
lifestyle the supports that it doesn't
mean it's going to happen overnight but
it's about working toward that and
helping other people understand that you
need that not just for yourself but it's
also for them so you can show up and be
the best damn version of yourself and so
when you do that you'll start to uncover
other things about your values so figure
out what your values are and I think
there are four types of values the first
type we wrote about in our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life so
that we call them the foundational
values health relationships passion or
what you might call creativity growth
and contribution I think everyone has
those basic sort of values and how you
get there with your different beliefs
will be different from their above that
you have these core values and those are
going to look pretty different for
everyone but these are the values that
really add value to your life so some of
mine for example your private dozen
maybe two dozen core values some of mine
might be freedom or autonomy or I mean
it's sexuality I mean there are these
different things that we value in our in
our lives that you and your partner are
going to have some similar values
compare and list is important but you're
also going to have some different values
it's going to help you understand
better support that person and then on
top of that you have minor values things
that you kind of like and do add value
from to your life but aren't necessities
in your life and above that are
imaginary values these are the things we
usually spend all our time on things we
think we're getting value from like
incessantly browsing Facebook or
attending meeting after meeting after
meeting things we pretend they're
valuable in our lives but don't add real
value and so we have to eliminate as
many those imaginary values as possible
and so we could focus on on the more
important values once you do that and
once you understand how your partner
does that it's less about the stuff in
your life and it's about where you're
working toward and you all have to
realize the most important thing you can
do is support that person and it's hard
to get there but there are a few steps
you have to go through to support
someone the acronym we use is Tara t-ara
you have to start by tolerating someone
and then you have to work toward
accepting them for who they are and
accept that they're at a different point
than where you are and they may never be
at the same exact point and that's okay
for that to be that that way but you
have to be able to accept that first
before you get to the next step is a big
lead to the next step that R stands for
respect you have to respect that person
for who they are not who the person you
wish they were or that you wish they
would be but you need to respect them
for the person who they are and the
person that they aspire to be once you
get past that but sort of the highest
level the hardest level to get to is to
appreciate appreciate that other person
for who they are warts and all and even
be thankful for for those those
differences because it's those
differences that keep a relationship
passionate and engaged and worthwhile I
think the only thing I would say man is
it sounds like sounds like you guys are
on the same page I mean the fact that
she's jumping into it with you that's
pretty awesome man I mean like I was
saying earlier if it wasn't for Mariah
being so supportive this would not be
easy it would be a lot harder and you
know for anyone out there who who has a
partner that is jumping on board with
you or supporting you would another way
to look at it you got to wake up every
day and say thank you to each other
like you got to go out of your way every
single day to show that person how much
you appreciate them I mean every single
day I ask myself like have I showed
Mariah today like how much I do
appreciate her and the way you can do
that is is is by supporting her
you know I with Mariah I never never
told her she had to get rid of anything
you know when I first we first started
dating and I was over at her house and I
saw in her closet
like just wall-to-wall clothes and like
80 pairs of shoes and I just remember
looking at that thinking well if this
goes any further I've got to be willing
to accept all that stuff into my house
if we ever move into each other like I
really have to not just accept it but
appreciate who she is and because our
values and beliefs are so in alignment
and because we are supportive towards
one another we love each other we
respect one another I was totally
willing to to bring that stuff and into
my life if it really was necessary now
over the last it'll be four years in
November that we've been we've been
together and I don't think I don't think
she knows it but she is a minimalist at
this point no she she has over the last
four years like totally got rid of a few
pairs of shoes here a few pairs of shoes
there and yeah dude like I would have
gotten rid of and I did with the packing
party I mean I would have gotten rid of
stuff so much faster but at the end of
the day like every time she was going
out of her way to pare down her wardrobe
not again not because I was like forcing
it on her but because she realized like
yeah I don't wear half of these clothes
let me figure out what I'm actually
wearing the same thing with her shoes
that she would just start pairing stuff
down and I would just be like oh that's
great I am so happy that you know you
were able to do that today how does that
feel and you know we talked about it and
after you know for years like now like I
said maybe she would call herself a
minimalist at this point but it was all
you know hindsight but the fact that you
know your wife is is supporting you as
best
you can then you know you've got a
supporter as but as best as you can and
maybe she doesn't move as fast as you
but but that's alright man it's hard to
find that type of relationship these
days thanks guys
[Applause]
all right man before you start this this
right now is time for the hashtag ask
the minimalists lightning round where
Josh and I we usually answer questions
from social media but that would be
weird if we're on our phones and we have
you right in front of us so here's how
it works you're gonna ask a question
Josh and I are going to do our best to
give you like a short pithy tweetable
answer usually we have about a week to
come up with these pithy answers and now
we've got about you know five seconds so
we might ramble on a little bit but the
whole idea is kind of like a rap battle
you guys get to decide who has the best
pit the answer by your applause and then
the winner what does the winner get well
I might give you your pride back howdy
what's your name my name is Jamie hey
Jamie
thanks for coming I appreciate you guys
coming I saw the documentary last summer
and just got really into it and started
doing some research haven't read the
book yet but I'm getting there beautiful
let's uh hey Jesse you around here
anywhere if we if we can give Jamie a
copy of everything that remain so I
don't feel like I'm selling him the book
but by the way after by the way if you
want to purchase a copy of the book they
will be available in the lobby afterward
but in all seriousness if you can't
afford a copy and you're here tonight or
you forgot your wallet or you just don't
have the money
whatever it is we'll be happy to give
you a copy let us buy you a copy if you
want a copy of any era books we're happy
to do that for you and ladies and
gentlemen Jessica Williams
you know what Jessica live tweets from
the show she helps us out with our
social media she does the merchandise
she straightens Ryan's hair and I tell
you so she'll do live tweeting if any of
you are sharing any photos tweets quotes
from tonight you can just use the
hashtag less is now that's the name of
the tour we're on right now and you can
see a bunch of other people's stuff as
well using that all right I'll let you
continue with your question sorry about
that yeah fantastic that's a lightning
round I hope good luck with this one so
I'm a single parent of a 15 year old son
so that's a challenge in of itself
he's minimalist cuz he never leaves his
room but that actually there's a TV show
about that called Porter's when he was
two years old he was diagnosed with type
1 diabetes so he has a chronic
life-threatening illness that he has to
deal with day in and day out in order
for me able to maintain his ability to
live on a day-to-day basis I have to
provide insulin diabetes supplies all
that kind of stuff and that either needs
insurance or some kind of health care so
I'm fortunate to have a very good
corporate job in health care that allows
me to do that but the conflict is if I
want to minimize things and get out of
the corporate kind of rat race how does
that balance with having to still
provide for my son who has a
life-threatening illness that if I
decide okay I don't want to work in the
corporate world how can I provide that
makes sense yeah it makes a lot of sense
and it's an important question
especially in the times that we're in
right now because by the time this
episode comes out the healthcare walls
might be different for all we know right
and and and so I think I think
regardless of what the health call care
laws are and what what the availability
/ access is which by the way are two
completely different things just because
something is available I was listening
to
friend of ours : right who Ryan
mentioned earlier here's a great podcast
called let's know things and he was
talking about this about
just because you something's available
to eat doesn't mean you have access to
it for example Jessica does handed you
that book but if you were illiterate
like you might have availability but you
wouldn't be able to access the
information inside the book and I think
the same it can also be true with with
health care right like even if it's
supposedly you have access to it but
it's not available it may be it's
available you don't have access to it
those things are all importantly even if
you have great health care but you can't
get a doctor to help you then then that
health care doesn't do you any good and
and so I don't have a definitive answer
for you I mean my I here's my pity
answer then I'll try to unpack it a
little bit when you don't know the
answer to something the three most
powerful words are I don't know and
that's really why why let me unpack that
that's why Ryan and I are doing this
right now I don't have a good answer for
you and I wish I did and I wish I could
tell you that minimalism is going to
solve all of your problems but it's not
and Ryan I certainly aren't that
self-important well what I know is that
if I were in your shoes and I was
looking to get away from that I have to
figure out how much money it would cost
to to walk away and I had to figure it
out in my own life not not just with
respect to health care which for me was
I was single at the time so it was
cheaper right you know I have a partner
and we have a four year old now so
health care costs are more expensive
although in Montana they're they're
relatively inexpensive compared to some
parts of the country and and I had to
budget for that accordingly so I had to
realize like if I'm going to live this
life one of the things that I'm that are
absolute necessities and for you health
care helped coverage health insurance is
one of those things that has to be
worked into a budget now I got my
lifestyle down to where I could live off
of about twenty thousand dollars a year
when I first walked away from the
corporate world and I'm not suggesting
that anyone else does that I'm saying
that was what worked for me and even now
that certainly wouldn't work for me
right now and so figuring out what that
number is will allow you to
identify what your walking or running
toward and whether or not that can
provide what you need
the other thing whenever you are running
toward that thing I found for me is
what's important is to not make money a
primary driver for doing what you're
doing right primary meaning first right
but it's going to be part of the
equation like Ryan and I are out on tour
right now and you all pay to get in here
and we're grateful you decided to pay to
get in here well most of you did we have
some friends we gave some tickets to but
but but in planning this like if four or
five hundred people show up like they
did tonight like we can't do this at a
coffee shop anymore and Ryan and I can't
afford on our own to rent out a theater
that would cost you know five thousand
dollars to rent out or something and so
in order to plan for that which okay
like I don't want to have to charge for
tickets what we're going to have to
start doing it if if we want to be able
to provide the level of quality that we
still want to provide and so money does
it is part of the equation but it's not
the primary driver for doing what I do
that's a second put the answer you know
first I want to say like Josh and I are
not against the corporate world any I
know people who have corporate jobs and
they love it and they're very happy with
with what they're doing it may not be
like the actual work that they're doing
but it's something that either does
align with their values and beliefs
maybe they're working on a non-profit so
maybe it is you know they enjoy what
they're doing or maybe they have you
know the time and the freedom to do
things that do align with their values
and beliefs so you know I think often
about what if like what if like all our
books spontaneously combust and like the
internet blows up and you know like the
rug is just swept out from underneath of
us and instagrams gone anyway ya know
hashtag what do I do
um just nobody put a hashtag so you know
I often think about that like what would
I do well when I first started this
whole journey like the idea was I'm
going to be a barista like I'm
to pay off as much debt as I can I'm
going to get to a point where hopefully
I am you know debt-free and I can make a
barista salary 23 25 thousand bucks
something like that and live my life um
when I got that idea I didn't just like
we did not just quit our jobs and start
a blog that's if anyone tells you that
that's the worst advice ever you know it
took us it took me about a year and a
half to really to really work a plan to
the point where you know when I got laid
off it was like it was real it was
relief because I had worked so hard up
to that point where I was like okay like
this I can actually handle it took Josh
a little while too now what is your plan
I don't know I don't know exactly
you know what that plan would take it
might mean I just got like a couple
random ideas right on through that I'll
just you know this is this is a just my
two cents which sometimes doesn't mean
any that's why I'm here yeah okay I'll
give it to you um you could you could
you could do one or two things you could
certainly look I mean there's more than
one or two things but here's a few
things I have I'm thinking of you could
go find another job that could afford
you the same health care maybe it pays
you a little bit less but maybe you're
still able to provide the care that your
son needs but that you know the first
question if you want to do that the
first question you got to ask yourself
is you know what does this current job
not providing you and if it's if there
is something that is lacking then that's
certainly an option um if you if you add
value to the company that you're with
right now I'm certain that they're going
to give you a good recommendation I'm
certain that you seem like a very high
herbal guy by the way I'm certainty what
happened you think no problem finding
another job the other thing I would say
too is instead of going to find another
job you go to your boss and set
expectations on like what you need in
order to make your job work and again
like if you're adding an extreme amount
of value they're going to work with you
I remember when Josh was when we were
still in the corporate world
Josh was on it on a date on Christmas
Eve and it's like 6 o'clock at night and
he's at dinner and our boss is calling
him just like repetitively and josh is
ignoring it josh is ignoring it and then
finally he picks it up he walks outside
can I help you yeah man I'm looking for
the sales numbers or those sales numbers
that josh is like I don't know I don't
know where we're at I just gave you an
update like 3:00 on with the Christmas
tree right like I just gave you an
update 3 hours ago yeah yeah but I need
numbers now my boss wants the number his
boss wants the numbers where are those
numbers and Josh was like you know I
don't have them and what you're asking
of me it's unreasonable at 6 o'clock at
night on Christmas Eve I'm out on a date
the stores are going to close in two
hours you'll have all that information
and mean just totally blew him away do
you think they fired Josh no in a fire
Josh because Josh added so much value to
that company he was able to get a little
leverage so I mean that's just a couple
options there are certainly more options
than that but I guess and I will get to
a pithy answer yeah what I'll say is you
know in the beginning of this talk where
I say you know minimalism you know think
about a life with more and then you know
I talked about how I'm not talking about
a perfect life I'm not even talking
about an easy life but a simple one and
I think it's too often that we get
simple confused with easy simple is not
easy so I here would be my pet the
answer is that um minimalism is not
about having an easy life it's about
having a well curated life thank you
thank you
hey guys Prabhat my name is Ross I'm
from Kentucky the other side of the
river okay thanks guys
you can always tell like just a little
bit other people always think I'm from
Kentucky so I say thank you
how's it going it's good my question is
so I recently graduated college I have a
good job I'm paying down my student
loans and are rapidly approaching the
question what now and you guys have
talked a lot about the five values that
you guys have and my question is how do
you how do you find that balance between
the values because it's really you can
see where it would be really easy to get
really focused on one and neglect some
of the others and so how do you balance
all those values that you have when you
only have so much time and so much so
many resources so here's what the answer
for you you're only as strong as your
weakest value and what I mean by that is
whenever I feel discontent in my life
whenever I feel something's out of lack
out of balance I have to look and start
to question those five values in
particular but then I'll look at my
other values after that but the
foundation you have to look at your
foundation first make sure that's solid
before you can look at the other stuff
and for me if there's some sort of
discontent it's like well you know what
I haven't been focused on my health the
way I should or and with me health has
been a really big issue the last couple
years in particular I've had just a ton
of issues that's what they're called
multiple chemical sensitivities which
makes it really hard to even breathe in
certain spaces I was up in that balcony
earlier today and like I was about to
die not literally although last year I
really did think I was dying at one
point and like to the point where I
updated my will and and was making some
other plans if I couldn't if I couldn't
get through what I was getting through
so I worked really hard on improving my
health and of course when you improve
your health then you're like okay I need
to make sure that my relationships are
strong because if it's feeling
discontent then am I giving to the
people closest to me or am i forsaking
them am i growing creatively or what we
might call passion right am I am i
growing as an
visible right personal growth or what
you might call meaning or purpose or
passion and also am i contributing to
the greater good am i giving to the
world around me and so what I try to do
is any of activity that I do throughout
my day
I usually hope that it it touches on
more than one of those values if you can
find all five great writing for me is
one that does touch on at least four of
those five values and and so if it
touches multiple values for you even
better it's it's time well-spent and
then how are you going to make up for
those other those other values and so
when you look at your daily schedule
ask yourself what what values does this
activity serve yeah for me man it's um
you know he mentioned those five values
earlier like whenever I'm feeling any
discontent like I look at those five
buckets so you get if you can imagine
them being like buckets of water the
least full bucket like that's as happy
as I am it's always different it's
always changing so you know I guess to
stay focused on your values it is
looking every single day on like where
where is that emptiest bucket and
sometimes it's obvious sometimes it's
not so obvious but you know with with
this whole journey in general it has
never been an endgame it's not like my
value is you know only owning 50 things
like Colin right I mean it's great for
him he travels all the time but I like
having a kitchen table
I like having game night and you know I
have a couple couches like I mean they
get used a lot um Josh does not have two
couches he's the game night sounds
miserable to him Josh is alert josh is
allergic to fun
[Laughter]
but but at the end of the day there is
no there is no end game and there's
never going to be you know one specific
value that is going to you know make you
happier there's not going to be one
specific thing that's going to fill
every single bucket I guess when I think
about values and beliefs I think about
priorities and if you were to ask me
what my priorities were when I was you
know 25 26 years old I would have told
you like we'll help if I'm not healthy
I'm not happy the leg I was staying out
to you know four o'clock in the morning
running up four hundred dollar bar tabs
and eating White Castle got in this
White Castle or I'd say you know it's my
relationships man those relationships
those are really important but my mom
lived like a half hour away and I did
not see here that often yeah that is a
big passion project that I want to work
on but I'll start on it next week you
know those were those of what I would
have said my priorities were but what I
realized is that you know I was just
giving those priorities of lip service I
guess to give you a pithy answer I would
say your priorities it's not what you
say they are it's what you do right
thanks guys
[Applause]
hi my name is Brian I'm an ENFP and I
suppose I'm up here mostly because I
enjoy the attention why do you think I'm
up here man this is great
Oh what I'd like to know is you guys you
know you guys are out on tour all the
time you've probably done these QAS a
few times and what would you say is the
question you always wish people would
ask but they never do you can pass the
microphone back and forth man I wish I
had like a really sexy answer for a hand
um no man you know this is not about
what I want I do love the attention
don't get me wrong
um but in the same token I really love
getting on the road I really love
answering emails I I love getting out
and having these conversations with
folks so you know I don't ever sit here
in the chair and think oh man like I
hope I get to bring up the 2020 rule on
this one or you know I hope I hope I get
to bring up the 9090 rule on this one I
don't ever feel that way um god I wish
had a sexy answer for you but I don't
that's why I put the answer you know I
was sort of going the hamster and my
head was spinning the wheel and there's
a question that is never asked I don't
know that I people rarely asked like
about like while we're on the road or
touring and because it is pretty
monotonous sometimes I'm like yeah we
rarely get questions about like what do
you would you have a pre-staged routine
or or because honestly most of what we
do while we're on tour and thankfully
we've learned a lot of lessons like we
just go out now for long weekends
basically so this weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday we're in
Indianapolis since that a Columbus and
then Cleveland and we go back home for
a couple weeks or whatever and so we've
learned lessons about that but actually
I know the reason that why people don't
ask about like what's your pre pre
staged routine or whatever is because
it's not about me and it's not about
Ryan you guys aren't here to just see us
you're here because this message it
resonates we happen to be the messengers
and so I feel grateful to be able to be
that but the only reason the spotlights
on me is because the literal spotlight
is on me and that was almost pithy that
was like fake profound we call that a
faux funded E but but in all seriousness
I know that that we're here because
we're here to share a recipe and all I
really hope is that you're able to
tweeze a few ingredients out and create
your own recipe for more simple life you
don't have to call yourself a minimalist
you don't have to even use the word
minimalism you know I know that turns
some people off even here in that word
you can call whatever you want call it
essentialism call it intentional ism
deliberate ISM you don't have to call it
anything at all I didn't until we
registered the domain the minimalists
com
it really really was just about a way of
regaining control and so I think any of
these questions they come up from people
we see people at our events factory
workers and executives show up at the
same event young old rich poor black
white we have high school dropouts and
college professors who were here tonight
probably and I heard one but not the
sound of one hand clapping
I've always wondered the answer to that
that olds in Cohen anyway what I've
learned from from all of these different
people no matter where you are on the
socio-economic spectrum where you are in
your life whether it's a five-year-old
who showed up in in San Diego and told
Ryan that she was giving away her shirts
or three years ago the 93 year old who
showed up also in San Diego with several
generations of daughters with her
I think we're old me I'm just becoming a
minimalist for the first time I think
the questions were asking the
fundamental questions underneath the
questions
have something to do with control like
we feel like we've lost a certain amount
of control in our lives we had control
at one point maybe it was when we
graduated high school or college and
everything we owned could fit into our
car and that felt free and alive and at
some point life stopped feeling so alive
it's that feeling so fresh and it
started feeling much more mundane or
routine or monotonous and we're living
but we're not really living right living
paycheck to paycheck isn't really living
because we're so focused on on just that
and don't get me wrong money is
important we all need some money to pay
the bills but it no longer has to be the
only thing that we worry about and I
think what people are asking is how do I
regain just some of that control and how
do I live a more meaningful life and
those questions manifest differently but
that's why I like what my morning
routine is before we go on tour like it
doesn't really it doesn't really matter
that's your question thanks a lot guys I
got us good I actually have to apologize
for the rest of the line we have we have
run out of time for questions we got to
move on to what we call our added value
segment and don't worry you'll get a hug
afterward we'll be hanging out after
like 20 minutes after this what will
will come out and will dish out hugs to
anyone who stays after we usually talk
about what's been adding value to our
lives recently but we'd like to do
something a little bit
more local so Ryan what has been adding
value to your life recently you know
it's funny like I was thinking about
what am I going to what am I going to
say for this portion of the podcast and
I started thinking of all the awesome
restaurants we have are they you unli
fare anymore but that you all have in
Cincinnati and I could sit here and you
know tell you about a you know an
amazing steak I added you know rubies or
the awesome duck at what is the
Montgomery Inn and then then so long but
I'm going to give you a recommendation
that you probably haven't heard of and
it is it's one of my top three favorite
restaurants in the world I would
actually say there's a place in Dayton
Ohio called ty9 it is out of this world
like Josh and I we joke around that when
we're on a tour we're on like you know
we're on the on a book tour but we're
also on the Thai food tour I have eaten
in so many Thai food places crazy all
across the world and I'm telling you ty9
has the best massaman curry that I've
had period there's a place in Seattle
that might come in you know a close
second but it does not touch tonight so
if you haven't been to Dayton if you
haven't been to Tainan go check it out
you're going to absolutely love it well
and we're also on a coffee tour when
we're on tour and so so we try to find
our favorite coffee shop in the town and
there's a new one it was new to me
collective espresso yeah it's here in
Cincinnati I was one and over-the-rhine
and I think they have one of the
location as well and I would encourage
you to check that check it out just
really well done really intentional and
give them a shot if you get a chance
real quick moving on to right here right
now let's talk about what's going on in
the lives of the minimalist well Ryan
and I are on the road right now if
you're listening to this at home
we're hitting 40 cities this year about
four cities at a time it will be all
over North America US and Canada you
find all the cities
dates over less is now calm also Ryan
and I are in the middle of building a
podcast studio and film studio together
and this is this is usually the part
where we talk about all of our
advertisers right haha I heard an
advertisement suck here's the truth you
hear about 5000 advertisements a day or
see or experience 5,000 advertisements a
day and I don't want this to be 5001
right so Ryan and I aren't going to be
up here talking about food delivery
services or mattress companies or
whatever you hear on underwear sweat
wicking underwear is the one that I've
heard a lot on podcast recently it's
it's not my judgement of other podcast
it just doesn't align with our values
there's our alarm but here's what I'll
tell you we are we do need some help
because we don't make any money from the
podcast other than what you all
contribute so if you're interested in
helped us build this podcast studio and
film studio we want to do a lot more
interesting stuff with the podcast we
want to do shorter versions of the
podcast longer versions we want to do
interviews episodes all of these
different things that we can't do right
now we also want improve the audio
quality but most important we want to
start doing more video stuff the
documentary resonated with so many
people we found that that medium using
video is a great way to go so if we can
do video interviews and video essays and
live streams that all cost some money
for us to do it so if you're willing to
donate a dollar or two per episode that
will help us out a lot you just go to
the minimalists com click on the donate
button there at the top we said this was
called a patreon page it allows you to
donate on a per episode basis by the way
none of that money goes to me or Ryan
100% of that will be used for the
podcast studio also to pay our producer
podcast Jean who's somewhere in the back
ladies and gentleman podcast Jean
even the shadows as as usual he is a man
of many hats he is our tour manager he's
our podcast producer he runs our
operations and he's an all-around
upstanding guy and we're really grateful
for you being here tonight Sean and
helping out but it also that helps us
pay him a full-time living wage which he
and his three kids are really happy
about so we can continue to do that also
we want to hire a full-time filmmaker to
do a lot more important video creation
so if you're willing to help out the
minimalists comm click on the donate
button you'll find all the information
over there and okay I want to thank
Bogaerts for having us here tonight
Thank You Bogaerts if you're listening
to this at home and you have a comment
or tip for anyone who asks as a question
today you can give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
we will air our favorite comments and
tips on a future episode before we leave
here I want to take one other person and
that person is you
you spend some money to get in here and
we certainly appreciate that allows us
to do some pretty cool stuff like pay
all of the venue folks here and and also
you gave up you give up more than your
money though you give up your two most
precious resources your time and your
attention and you could have spent that
time and attention anywhere else and you
chose to spend that with us and I'm
certainly honored I know Ryan is as well
and so if you leave here with one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works that's your time y'all good
morning minimalist
this is Irene from San Diego and this is
in response to Megan from Minneapolis
question about being in sales and also
still aligning with her values of being
minimalist I say if you love selling
apply to a company
me whose corporate values aligned with
minimalism I know that Patagonia has and
I'm not I don't work for Patagonia by
the way I'm not in any way connected
with Patagonia but I do know that they
have a corporate responsibility that is
aligned with mine where they know the
impact of their products and they
encourage people to recycle their
clothing and they also make clothing
that is meant to last for a really long
time and so there are I would say for
those of you who are in sales and are
looking to keep the current trajectory
of your career look up those companies
that are aligned with your values
because they do exist increasingly self
hi my name is Karen and calling from
Hartford during the UK I'm calling with
some tips today for anyone who's been
through bereavement recently it's a
tough thing to go through and you still
have to deal with all the objects that
are left behind and that's been quite a
difficult process for me number one tip
is remembering that the love is not in
the objects the love you have for that
person is not on the objects that's a
thing that I've heard before on the
podcast but it's been my little motto
for dealing with this my father passed
away in January and I've had a lot of
objects and things to go through of his
so I've just been saying that over and
over to myself and it's been very very
helpful
I love for him is in the things I did
for him when he was alive the times I
told him I loved him and in my memories
that I carry with me for the rest of my
life number two and this wouldn't be for
everyone is that I've chosen to make a
memory there after some of his old
clothing you can just find online if you
google memory there's lots of different
companies I've gone with one UK called
Lily's love that I found on Facebook but
not just for bereaved people's clothing
also they can make wedding dresses of
bears out of wedding dresses
there's outlaw baby clothing so if your
children have grown up it's another good
thing that you could think about doing
with the clothes the third thing is just
remembering that the greatest object my
parents could bequeath me is me
my flesh my blood they chose to raise me
and that's an amazing gift the gift of
life and it's really important that I
hang on to that I was surprised baby so
they didn't have to have me but they
carried on and I know parents aren't
always brilliant they don't always make
the best choices but they chose to try
they chose to try and raise me well and
I know that I only honor that gift if I
spend the time now looking after myself
as I live my life rather than stressing
over some old crockery or CDs hi I'm
Kathleen and I'm from Prince Edward
Island Canada and I was looking at my
bookshelf recently and there's a lot of
books on there that I haven't even read
and there's a good amount that I have
read but I just they're so like
meaningful to me and I've learned so
much from them and I really just can't
you know give them up so I was thinking
I'm actually a multitasker right on most
days so when I come home from work I
usually need to be on the go you know
like doing the dishes or taking my dog
for a walk and while I'm doing these
tasks I always like to have a story in
my ears like listening to a podcast or
an audio book so it got me thinking what
you could do if you're having a hard
time parting with books maybe try to
find the audio book version of the
physical book that you have and that way
you can have that book with you on your
phone or tablet or whatever and you can
access it whenever you like
and then you won't have the physical
book in your space you can free up that
space and another idea would be to get
the eBook version of the physical book
that you have so if you can try to find
that and that way it might be easier for
you to part with the books that you're
having such a hard time with letting go
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing is being that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you were fine
without it
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'd be fine without so tear your
eyes
[Music]